hello believe nation today I'm going to
talk about the seven ways to structure
your day for success so one of the most
common questions that I get asked is how
do i structure my day how do I set up my
schedule my time to have success
consistently be productive because as an
entrepreneur you've got a million things
going on you're wearing every hat in the
business and it would by the way you
want a personal life as well so today
I'm going to share with you the seven
ways to structure your day for optimal
success we number one is you need to
have a morning routine you need to have
a morning routine that inspires you that
gets you set up from the beginning from
the start of every single day to set you
up for success this is one of the
biggest things that entrepreneurs need
help with because maybe you watch this
video on a Thursday afternoon at 5
o'clock and you're working so hard you
get so inspired and motivated or maybe
you're meeting somebody or maybe you
listen to a podcast or something think
about what gets you so inspired because
often what happens is you then have tons
of productivity and then you wake up the
next day and it's gone and you're
starting over and the alarm goes off and
you're sluggish getting out of bed you
don't want to do it and you slowly grind
into your day until some other random
thing happens and then that gets you
fired up and you're off and running and
instead of having these peaks and
valleys where you're up and down and up
and down you're riding this
rollercoaster you want to think about
what gets you most excited motivated
inspired productive and plan that into
your morning routine daily to give
yourself the best shot at having a
productive day today where you're going
to go off and have a big impact well you
believe in that big crazy dream that you
have that you can make it happen
put that into your morning routine and
so for everybody's a little bit
different some of the common themes it
could be having music I love putting
music on first thing in the morning
something that gets me inspired and
pumped up and moving and dancing I love
watching videos the top tens the mentor
means I love reading books I love having
a exercise routine things that get me
going this is what works for me you need
to find what works for you and the best
way to
do it as think about when you have
already been inspired because you have
because you may not wake up every day
and start but you have been inspired in
your life before
chances are it's happened recently to
you what happened that led to that
inspiration and again instead of letting
that thing be this random occurrence
plan forward daily into your morning
routine to set yourself up for a
successful day number two is ask
yourself the question the most important
question you can ask yourself every
single day is what is the most value I
can bring to my business today this is
something that I'm obsessed with and
every day as I'm walking to the office
or walking here to China dance salsa I'm
thinking about what's the most value
that I could bring to my business today
because you have a ton of things on your
plate right entrepreneurs that I know
have a to-do list this long followed by
an ideas list which is even longer right
sound familiar you need to focus on the
thing that's gonna bring the most
immediate impactful value to your
business especially if you're a solo
entrepreneur especially if you don't
have a team to take care of some of the
things for you when you are literally
doing everything in your business ask
yourself every day what is the highest
value task that I can do today that will
advance my goals and then go and do that
[Music]
number three is have CEO time this ties
in to the last point you need to make
sure that every single day when you're
going to your business whether that is
actually going to an office if you're
sitting down in front of your computer
at home or going to a Starbucks then you
have CEO time every day and CEO time
what I consider to be CEO time is time
to focus on the business instead of in
the business or yes you have a million
things you do you got tons of emails to
get back to you've got lots of social
media to post out there everybody wants
a piece of you you've got an ideas list
again that's a mile long
you need to have CEO time I recommend at
least 90 minutes a day of CEO time we
are not just caught in the day-to-day
running of the business and stuck on
that mouse wheel you're just going
around around around around around in
circles if you don't ever
have time to focus on planning and the
bigger picture for your business and
guess what you're never gonna get to the
bigger picture for your business
you're gonna stay stuck where you are so
planned CEO time every day into your
business I prefer it in the morning I
prefer before you open up your email
before you let your day explode on you
because you wake up you go to the office
you look at your email and suddenly your
day is over
you're just constantly responding to
other people so whether you call it eat
that frog or first priority's first or
lots people different names for it
making sure that you plan that into your
schedule before your day blows up on you
is important if you want to escape where
you are because otherwise you're gonna
stay here instead of being a grow out
here number four is chunk your time
anything that you do multiple times per
day you want to try to chunk it down to
one time per day it makes a huge huge
huge difference in your productivity and
how you structure it so that you can get
more important stuff done and the
classic one is emails or phone calls
because if somebody emails you and you
look at it even if you don't address it
immediately it's still you're thinking
about it and it distracted you from
doing what you should be doing which is
whatever task you're working on and this
is especially important when you're
doing creative tasks when I'm working on
my book when I'm writing the manuscript
when I'm doing important research I'm so
in the zone of focus there that if you
tap me on the shoulder or you send me an
email you try to call me and on the
phone but you try to call me
it takes me you know half an hour just
to get back to where I was
so that five-second interruption isn't
really a five second interruption you
screwed over a good chunk of my day and
so thinking about those important things
that happen to you multiple times per
day how do you chunk that down so I'm
only doing a one time a day I'm focused
on just doing that for the day and it
means that you lose you lose some small
potential wins right like if you're only
checking email at 12 o'clock as an
example then maybe some really important
media opportunity comes up and they need
an answer by 11 o'clock and you didn't
see it in time and so you don't get that
media opportunity you can't get every
single small win
gonna happen it's not possible you can't
be on 24/7 it is not possible and so you
have to be comfortable with losing some
of the small wins because the time that
you're spending that is so focused is
allowing you to go create something
bigger and amazing chunk your daily time
[Music]
number five is chunk your week
so just like we chunk multiple times per
day - once a day anything you're doing
multiple times per week do once per week
so I look at this filming videos as an
example I film all the videos for my
channel pretty much on a Wednesday
afternoon I'll stand here at Toronto in
salsa I'll set up the lights and the
gear and the camera and the books and
the microphone and all that and make
twenty videos for the week and it does a
couple of things why is it so important
like why not do three videos a day
instead of twenty videos in one day one
because there's set-up time and takedown
time and this applies to anything
whatever you want to get into whatever
tasks you have there's set-up time and
takedown time for this I need to set up
the lights and the camera and the books
and the microphone all that softening to
get it all ready and so it's much more
time-saving for me to do it all at once
all the videos at once instead of having
that set up and take down time each time
the second thing is task switching is
difficult so when I'm in video mode I'm
in video mode I'm just focused on the
videos I can bring the energy from one
video to the next video to the next
video where it's so hard for me to go
from video mode extroverted energy
enthusiasm into research mode where it's
headphones on they'll talk to me
introverted analyzing try to figure
stuff out and it take me from that state
introverted getting work done to hey
come and be on a video I'm gonna I'm
gonna have energy like this like I'm not
I'm gonna be distracted I'm not gonna be
as a beat I'm gonna be thinking about
other things and it won't be a good
video even now I already have less
energy who wants this on video and so
understanding that your energy will
change with different kinds of tasks is
important and so whatever is happening
multiple times per week try to do it on
one day
per week so for me what my schedule
looks like now Monday I'm working on all
the video research for this channel
reviewing all the videos seeing what has
to be changed what I like what I don't
like making modifications and in the
afternoon I'm doing book promotion work
could be research again on the book or
could be reaching out to influencers or
could be making thank-you videos you
know I'm kind of in that zone Tuesdays I
spend the whole afternoon doing in
Toronto dance also work Wednesdays I'm
doing videos all afternoon Thursdays and
doing phone calls and interviews and
meetings and then Friday is my CEO day
where I'm spending the whole day doing
CEO bigger picture stuff and it really
really really really really really works
and again you have to be willing to give
up the small wings to go for the big
wins number six is value your time I
don't think people value their time
enough
I don't think entrepreneurs value their
time enough if I audited your date and
look at what you were actually doing
during the day there'd be a lot of waste
of time all the time you spend on
Facebook or clicking refresh on your
statistics to see how many people watch
your YouTube videos in the past hour and
going back and check in again or check
in your sales numbers over and over and
over and over again yes you could work
harder yes you can add more hours to
your day because you need to get more
work done but I would say that a huge
chunk of your current day even if you
work 0 extra hours could be way more
productive because you're just not
focused and that's a harsh truth that's
something that's hard to say and hard to
realize but if you look at your schedule
you look at the tasks that you're
actually doing during the day and you
constantly self-audit to say is this
really the best use of my time and then
start to make adjustments based off of
that because a lot of entrepreneurs
complain that they don't have enough
time but really you're not valuing your
time enough and you're doing things that
you shouldn't be doing
[Music]
and number seven is to invest in
yourself I'd make sure that you find
time at least once a week if not every
day to invest in yourself to learn to
grow to try new things to make yourself
better because as you grow as you gain a
knowledge and experience and expertise
your business will grow and so that
could be meditation works really well
for some people it could be gratitude I
have a daily gratitude practice that I
do every single day to remind me of the
things that I have and fortunate my life
it could be watching videos to learn and
be inspired it could be reading the
could be out trying to understand the
new topic it feels you it makes you feel
better it puts you in a better mood and
it gives you more of not just the
inspiration but also the tactics of what
to do one of the things that really
helped me in my early days as an
entrepreneur was reading this book
radicals and visionaries every single
morning and it was just three of the
four pages of a different entrepreneur
that helped me get in the zone of being
inspired but also give me some tactics
of what I could do and so now I don't
want I don't read the book anymore but I
watch videos and it gives me the
motivation and also the ideas of what I
can do and so you need to make sure that
you're spending time at least every week
investing in yourself factor that in
don't let it happen by accident or
randomly on the weekend somewhere book
it into your calendar every single week
for every single day so you are
constantly learning and growing so
that's my view on the seven ways to
structure your day for success I'm
curious to figure out what did you guys
think what did you guys like the most
what did you agree with or what did you
not agree with and would you add an
eight nine ten to the list something I
missed out let me know leaving the
comments below I'm gonna join in the
discussion I also want to give a quick
shout out to Daria Bardot thank you so
much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word it really really really
really means a lot to me so thank you
guys for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one where it is much
love I'll see you soon